hello and welcome to the 2013 throw tech
for awesome thank are you there or is it
just blah blah I'm just gonna let this
happen and gentlemen my insane brother I
love editing you scooping the brains out
of a squirrel right now it is the most
disgusting video we have ever done
squirrel needed to see a dentist real
bad I blame Obama oh that's the sweetest
thing I've ever seen am I gonna hoola
for you good question
here's a good answer now put your pees
in my news you get to work every morning
at 6 o'clock
do do you want to come work for me
because you could literally sleep in
three extra hours every day yes did you
see I'm concerned that the patriarchy
might not even survive to the end of the
project for awesome just kidding just
kidding it's it's deeply in the truth
we're having a new perk right now and
nothing I'm wearing it yesterday well
first of all he's a smaller man than I
this is not what it looks like then I
like the number of people watching this
just sharply decreased so I don't know
how to take the how do you make a cat
looks like Benedict Cumberbatch well
[Music]
like the court model clear things up
amazingly yeah putting his ruff it's
like for horses just so that I can sit
there and have the authentic experience
of properly eating salami this is my
first ever spoken already piece it's
called the police
why are you doing pelvic thrusts you
told me to tap dance on the hugging out
today
my hair is how did you so precisely get
your eyes no I've been practicing like
this except it won't already be on
cardboard it will just be you know just
a poster that you can roll and unroll
but it'll look like this what is my
Sharpie face removal and why didn't I
think about this before I started to
cover in the face and shortly Jodie had
them apple bottom jeans and boots with
the her the whole club was a looking at
her three two one
zoom in zoom in now we're looking at my
blood mousse this is my favorite time of
year to be a nerdfighter and it's what
I'm proudest at the nerdfighter
community because I get to see the work
that we do together I know that it's
hard to take me seriously when I'm
covered still slightly covered in
sharpie feel you bro and thanks for
getting me into this mess the project
for awesome IndieGoGo page is open for
another 36 hours you can still get all
kinds of amazing things there my
Christmas album John sneak peek of the
new thing that he's writing write it for
awesome t-shirts posters commemorative
coins men and women of YouTube charity
calendars like Ally Rhonda's actual
headshots from when he was like 15 years
old and my fake headshot from when I was
8 also yes The Fault in Our Stars as a
movie poster and this is the only way
that you could get it so if you want to
get that it's only 25 bucks
and it's all for charity it's a donation
all I gotta say is thank you thank you
to everybody who commented who watched
the livestream made of video donated
money thanks to everybody who came and
joined us on the live show and who
participated the men and women of
YouTube charity calendars of course
thanks to our amazing volunteer support
staff who stayed up all hours of the day
and night with us thanks to Michael
Aranda who designed the poster and the
t-shirt thanks to karen kavett and is on
the calendar the website and thanks to
our web developer sam Rudge and fastly
our hosting service who did it for free
this really is one of my favorite parts
of my life so thank you all for being so
great John I'll see you on Tuesday
[Music]